hello everyone today I found an
interesting article on chess calm it was
written by grigory sir / the Grandmaster
I'm sure you all remember his name I
showed his name and my channel is the
one where white sacrifices all of his
pieces if you haven't seen it do check
it out I will put a link to it in the
description below but he wrote an
article called the greatest power of
combinations you've never seen and I
checked out the article and I checked a
couple of games and I have no idea who
these people were
he's playing against and I have no idea
when these games were played that never
heard about this and later when you go
through the entire article in the end of
the article there it is this is not
Garry Kasparov this is Sergey Kasparov a
belarus grandmaster and this is a one
game I chose he's playing against in
turn an international master from
Ukraine elects a Soviet knee the game
was played in 2001 it was an open
tournament in Egypt and I chose this
game because it features one of my
favorite openings and I don't think I've
ever shown a game in this opening maybe
once the opening I'm referring to is the
Bangkok gambit a variation of the benoni
so for those of you who enjoy this
opening I'm sure you'll enjoy this game
and for those of you who maybe never
heard of it maybe you maybe you'll find
it interesting and try it out in your
own games so so let's see this
interesting game by mr. Sergei Kasparov
what here
alexei opens it with the d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 and c5 so going for the
benoni defense we have d5 now b5 this is
the Banco gambit and white accepts the
gambit C captures on b5 here we have a
six offering a second point and we have
B captures on a6 so this is the fully
accepted Banco gambit the ship captures
on a6 now Knight to c3 d6 Knight to f3
and the here black has a couple of
options he can go g 6 e sixth exchange
in the center but mr. Kasparov goes for
Knight B to d7 and here is a I played
this position quite some times and
if I play this position against the
weaker player and then he never gets the
idea of playing efore here because of
Bishop captures Bishop on f1 and his
castling the options will be ruined so
people often go here for
I know g3 or something but actually e4
is considered to be the best move here
so this is what steady at any place
efore we have Bishop captures an f1 King
captures an f1 and it seems you've lost
the castling but why it was simply
played g3 King g2 and bring the rook
into the game no problems there g6 we
have g3 now Bishop to g7 King to g2 and
black doesn't really have a way of
stopping this he still has to develop
his pieces and castle so white has
plenty of time to accomplish this
because part of castles we have rook to
e1 and now rook to a6 and here you white
still didn't develop the bishop the
Queen this rook on a 1 isn't really
doing anything so proper thing to do
would definitely be to develop the
bishops we have Bishop to form a between
to d3 but here he decided to go for the
immediate be 5 and there was no reason
to do this
we have night cap night on G tonight it
goes to G for e 6 now F captures D
captures on e6 attacking the knight and
now Bishop captures on c3 first we have
B captors and now Knight to e5 and here
white white must capture this Knight
knife characters knight Knight captures
night and after Queen d5 the game
continues probably Queen to a8 offering
a trade and after Queen captures rook
captures and yes black does have this
very nasty attack on the a2 pawn but
black can go Bishop to g5 attacking b7
pawn and then maybe even defend which
work to e2 so it's a pretty equal
position and the white does have a
bishop against the Knights and so
something white should have gone for but
he probably didn't like this idea of
ropes being doubled on the a file and he
decided to play Bishop to f4 here and
better for is a move that loses
immediately now I will just show you the
next
Kasparov played the next move is Queen
to a8 now pinning this knight on f3 and
it doesn't really matter that the bishop
on f4 is attacking the knight here
because if you move the bishop then the
rock on f8 is also attacking the pin
piece now here h3 was played which is
the strongest move and this is the
position I wanted you to really see and
I would like you to pause the video here
and find the winning the winning move
for mr. Kasparov now if you okay if you
find the g5 g 5 is also winning I will
show that after I show you the entire
game but there's an even there's an even
fancier move have to put it so more more
more beautiful I don't know how to put
it but I want to define that I remove
not g5 so do pause the video and trying
to find the solution give it a couple of
minutes or you know you can always do it
later
so I do hope it was the video for those
of you who managed to find the move
congratulations you're very strong and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show the move Kasparov played here is
actually night 2 h2 and what was the
idea well he is attacking the pink piece
once again and if you captured were
looking for example King captures then
after Knight captures an f3 it's all
over it's check the rook is gonna fall
and you can see that the knight is
covering the h2 square and the G 1
square so the King has to go on either G
2 or H 1 both white squares and both
covered by the Queen so after the King
moves Queen will simply gobble up the
rook with a double check now from the
Queen and the room in the night and
after King to f1 now night to see to
simply threatening Queen to h1 a full
board combination Queen captures now
Queen h1 King moves and now Queen
captures on a1 black is black is up 2
rooks ok a rook and in exchange but it's
completely lost position for white next
move is rook captures an a2 this is
completely lost
but of course after this after this
sorry
after this Queen to a8 and h3 after
night - H - of course skin captures on
h2 wasn't played what white plate was
rook captures on e5 d captures on e5
now you either have to move the bishop
as your Bishop is attack but if you move
the bishop then again rook from f8 is
attacking the knight on f3
so here King captures on h2 but now
comes he captures on f4 now you're
threatening F captures on g3 this will
come with check and it will open up the
rook on f8 g for now preventing this and
now rook captures an e2 threatening to
capture the rook also eyeing the f2 pawn
so rook captures Queen captures now
again threatening to capture on f2 Queen
e1 defending and now Queen to d5
attacking the knight on f3 Queen G -
King to g2 defending and now rook to f6
and in this position
Ukrainian international master alexis
Rodney resigns the game as he's down to
much material he's losing this pawn and
there's really nothing to do here if you
go for some Queen to be one ideas with
the idea of going Queen b8
black and always play simply King to g7
then grab the pawn and then win the game
and if you try to exchange black will
happily exchange and then the rook is
simply much better than night in this
position so yeah after this after this
rook to f6 move a white resigned the
game and once again congratulations to
everyone who was able to find this and I
mean I really got tricked by this
article as I was really watching those
games and they did seem I know Kasparov
played the Bangko gambit in maybe a
couple of unofficial games I don't think
he ever employed I don't he employed the
Benoni and a couple of tournament games
but I've never heard of as part of
actually playing the Bangko gambit so I
was very interested in this
only later finding out that it was
actually Belarus the Grandmaster Sergei
Kasparov but nevertheless you know I
I probably never would have heard about
circuit as part of without that article
so I will put the article in the
description as well so you can check it
out to read more about him if you'd like
but I will just show the idea in that
position that would have occurred after
Bishop to f4 Queen to 8 and now h3 the
move I suggested for you to find was
night 2 h2 but also possible was g4 g5
here as simply attacking this piece
making it move or white will capture the
night and then black will capture the
bishop
so we can't really move it as then
you'll go free the rook on f8 so H
captors on g4 now G captures on f4 and
after G captures on f4 now rook captures
on f4 now there's a triple attack on the
night here and white really doesn't have
anything here
he can play rook captures on e5 but
that's just giving up for the exchange
or he could try rook to e3 but then
comes rook a to a four now doubling up
on the fourth rank and after rook to be
1 and now comes Knight captures rook
captures rook captures Queen captures
and of course if the Queen captures then
rook captures on g4 and white is lost
pink has to move and then Queen captures
Queen so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it hope you learned
something about someone else called
Kasparov as I don't know it kind of it
must suck you know to have your last
name because part of if you're not Garry
Kasparov because the world will probably
never hear about you as you know Garry
Kasparov was the world champion and
strongest player in the world for quite
some time but yeah that's why there's
this video for you to hear about mr.
circuit Kasparov and I do hope you
enjoyed it I hope you learned something
about the but only the Bangko gambit and
if any of you do do employ it in your
own games do share in the comments I
would like to thank Jules Coulson Martin
Franco and the dalla wakka for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and
we'll see soon